[Music]
hey you guys it's tomes of terror and
we're talking about another
horror book although this one's actually
kind of more of a thriller
now this one came out in 2016 i believe
initially this is behind closed doors
by b.a paris now apparently
this was uh b.a paris's first novel
she's written
three since then subsequently which i
haven't read this was actually the first
one of hers that i read
and i just saw a whole bunch of
different recommendations for this one
like whole bunch of people picked it as
you know their favorite read of the year
whatever so
again i felt like i should pick it up
and see what all the fuss was about
now it seems though it's very strange
because it seemed like initially when i
was first
reading about this book or like watching
other reviews of this book
it seemed like they were just
overwhelmingly positive but then the
more i looked at it
there did seem to be some people that
just really really hated it like just
one two stars and blah blah i'm falling
somewhere in the middle
i think on goodreads i gave it like
three and a half four star or something
like that
it's an it's a really entertaining read
it's a really quick read
but you know it's not particularly deep
it's not particularly twisty it's not
particularly clever or anything like
that it's you know it's pretty standard
but i don't really mean that to sound
derogatory because
i actually did really enjoy it and like
i said you know i read it really quickly
because i was like interested to see
what was going to happen next
but if you're expecting this really
intricate intricately plotted kind of
uh you know thriller with all these kind
of moving parts
this isn't really that i mean the story
is pretty simple
it's a psychological essentially a
psychological horror story about a
hair a terrible marriage you know a
woman that marries a psychopath
so it has a little bit of a lifetime
movie vibe but again i don't really mean
that to sound
derogatory this is just something that
essentially like a summer beach read i
guess
but but maybe a little bit more
disturbing than your
average summer beach read i don't know i
don't go to the beach so i don't really
know what
people read on the beach i'm just saying
so now this one i'm
not really all that worried about
spoiling this one so as i said if you
don't want to know anything about this
i will say that the uh the description
on the back of the book
is pretty straightforward and if you
read the description you can pretty much
guess where it's going so it's not like
there's any surprises or anything
but i will say that um if you don't want
to know anything anything about the book
like i usually say
then probably read the book and then
come back later because
um i think i probably will be spoiling
this one like i said it's not like
the enjoyment of the book doesn't really
come from you know being surprised or
there being big plot twists or anything
like that it's pretty much
you know the big reveal you know of
the dude being a psychopath is happens
really really early
and then just from that point onward
you're just kind of like
seeing how things unfold you know
towards a pretty much
inevitable conclusion so as i said i
think spoilers are not really all that
important for this
but if you don't really want to know
anything about it then turn it off and
come back
because i will be spoiling the end so
the story of this one as i said it's
fairly straightforward
now there's a woman named grace and
she i guess she kind of had uh she's in
london and um
i forgot to mention too that ba paris is
also she's a british author although she
lived
a lot of her time in france and i
believe she was a teacher and she was in
finance like prior to her becoming a
novelist
so grace the main character uh
she was like a buyer for harrods she had
you know a really decent life but one
thing
that one thing that's kind of you know
was kind of missing for her was that she
didn't really have a relationship she
had boyfriends and stuff but
the main thing that seemed to be getting
in the way was that
she has a younger sister named millie
who has down syndrome and she
adores millie and is essentially
i mean millie is at kind of a state
school but she's going to be 18
soon so you know she'll need someone to
you know to go live with like a relative
to go live with like once she
when she reaches 18 years old and since
uh grace and millie's parents seem to be
like
yeah no thanks we're out we're going to
new zealand um you know you guys are on
your own so grace very happily
volunteers she's like yeah of course you
know millie can live with me when she
you know comes home from the school
and since grace had you know such a nice
job and everything like that she could
afford to
take care of her and she is in fact
paying for her school until she
reaches the age of majority so as i said
you know boyfriends
you know have been kind of coming and
going because some people are like oh
you know you
you come as a package deal like you have
a sister with down syndrome who's always
gonna be with you and a lot of dudes are
like yeah no thanks you know so there's
that whole thing however
one day she and millie are out in a park
and there's a band playing and they're
watching it
and millie starts she gets up and starts
dancing
and a lot of the people in the crowd are
kind of like uncomfortable or they're
kind of like
um can you like stop her from doing that
it's like it's really embarrassing or
whatever
but then all of a sudden this real suave
handsome [ __ ]
comes out of the crowd and goes to dance
with millie and dances with her for the
whole song and everything
and this dude is a guy named
jack angel now
jack seems like the perfect man
which should cause red flags to be
flying up all over the place
but hey grace hasn't had any in a long
time i guess
and herself so she's kind of like
sure so sure her guard is uh is not up
as well as it should be maybe
so basically jack who i don't know if
they mean to imply that he looks like
george clooney because there's a whole
thing about
millie and and george clooney and all
this other kind of stuff which she'll
which you'll see if you read the book
but i thought it was meant to imply that
he kind of looked like him but anyway
he's like super handsome
he's super rich he's um a lawyer
and he's made his whole career out of
defending um battered women or like
putting
uh you know abusers like spousal abusers
into prison and he has never lost a case
so everybody just thinks he's an awesome
[ __ ] dude
he's kind of like he's very gentlemanly
he's very
attractive he's very he seems very
compassionate
and uh you know and for a while
he seems to set his sights on grace and
be like you're the woman for me and i
want to marry you and all this other
stuff
and um obviously you know if if you're
reading this and
you're a human particularly if you are a
human woman
you will know that every like pretty
much all the [ __ ] the dude says in the
beginning it's like yeah it'd be nice
but
it sounds like a bunch of [ __ ] to me
and indeed it does turn out to be so
what ends up happening now the way the
book is written
it goes back and forth from the past to
the present
so you know it's it uh you know so one
chapter this is
you know what's happening right now and
then here's a chapter and so i think
that i can't remember i think it's in
maybe a year
so we're going back and forth and then
basically they just keep flipping back
and forth between past and present until
like past
and present you know meet up in the
middle i guess essentially so that's
kind of how it's structured
which um i actually thought was a pretty
good structure
like it kept it uh moving along pretty
well and then like you
because it was kind of interesting to
see what was going on now
and you're just kind of like okay well
that doesn't really seem right or
anything like that but then
you know the next chapter they would go
she would go back to the past and she
would talk about stuff that happened in
the past like to provide context
so it kind of just goes back and forth
like that so at the very beginning of
the book
um because like i said you don't find
out all this stuff about the park and
about him being like oh millie's so
awesome and
you're so awesome for taking care of her
and of course she can live with us and
you know our lives are going to be
perfect and awesome and all this other
kind of stuff and grace being like uh
yeah sounds good
and they get married after only six
months again big huge red flags just big
[ __ ] red flags all over the place
it's just like [ __ ] it's like a
[ __ ] bull fight up in here at all the
red flags flying around
but yeah so she doesn't see it at first
that's you know
okay so at the very beginning i like
that uh ba paris opened the book like
this it opens in the present
and it's a dinner party
that jack and grace are giving and
they're of course beautiful perfect
house
and grace who as i said was kind of a
high-powered she was a buyer for harrods
department store which if you don't know
is like a really really prestigious like
really like a really well regarded big
you know department store in
london but she has left her job
to be a full-time homemaker essentially
uh so she does gardening she does
cooking and everything
and uh also she looks super perfect all
the time it's like she always
she never has a hair out of place
everything she wears is just like
immaculate she always looks
good so at the beginning you're kind of
put into this world it's this gorgeous
house it's this dinner party some of
their friends it's like some couples and
stuff
and you're kind of getting an insight
into grace's mindset
while she's doing this but you don't you
know something's off
but you don't know exactly what yet i
mean you do because
i mean like i said this there are really
no surprises in this story it's like
obviously i was reading it in like two
or three pages and i'm like oh well
obviously like jack is a psychopath and
he's like making her act
like that and he has like total control
over her so it's not like it's any big
revelation or anything
but it's interesting like all the little
details that they drop and all the
little kind of
you know ways that she's really really
worried about
you know did everything she cooked turn
out perfectly it's like is she allowed
to eat this it's like if somebody else
eats part of her dessert she's gonna get
in trouble and like all this other kind
of stuff
so there's all these like little
subtleties and like between the the
conversations that they're having with
one another
so it turns out that at this dinner
party i guess so this has been going on
for a while
um this whole [ __ ] up scenario
which i'll get more into in a little bit
but
the new component of this whole [ __ ] is
that a new
girl a new woman rather has moved into
town whose name is esther i think
and even though it seems like all jack
and grace's other friends
are just kind of like well you guys are
just perfect and you guys are so in love
you have the most beautiful house you
have the most beautiful clothes you have
the most
beautiful parties it's like you guys
never argue blah blah
and it seems like all of jack's friends
buy into that
but esther doesn't seem to
so because she's kind of the one of the
only smart people in this book
i have to say because she immediately is
just kind of like
yeah something doesn't smell right
around here so she kind of starts not
being
you know she's not being a dick or
anything like that but she is kind of
asking some questions like oh grace you
know i
you know you seemed like such a um you
so accomplished at your job it's like
doesn't it bother you to be home all day
you know you know she's just kind of
like trying to draw her out and like
make friends with her a little bit
and so grace is having to like navigate
through this
minefield of like [ __ ] man like how can
i answer without
getting punished for it later on so
there's all that kind of [ __ ] going on
and then as i said you know when when
you get that like the dinner party scene
which is the first
scene which is actually really good
because you get a lot of insight into
the way that their dynamic is perceived
by everyone around them and as i said i
think
i don't find it entirely believable that
i don't know is it maybe that's
maybe that's not the case but i did feel
like i
some of the people should have known
that something was
weird i don't know but um so the thing
about jack
is he's 40 years old as i said very
successful and everything
and no one thought it was that weird i
guess like that he hadn't been married
previously or you know even seemed to
have any kind of serious relationships
or
anything like that because he said i was
just waiting for the right woman and
here she
is you know and all this other stuff but
as the story goes on
we discover that you know much like
these kind of psychopathic
dudes in a lot of you know lifetime
movies or these types of thrillers
the guy has like a perfect facade
everyone thinks he's wonderful
but he's actually like the most evil
[ __ ] on the planet and
like he has just really really [ __ ] up
yeah he just has like no empathy no
nothing he's just like a monster so
basically what ends up happening and as
i said
it goes back and forth from the past to
the present is that
very shortly after like he was basically
the perfect man
up until they get married and then they
go
on their honeymoon to thailand and
basically on the first night of their
honeymoon
he just lays it all out he's like look i
just married you because
one i just want to torture you because i
get off on
women being afraid of me and controlling
every aspect of their life
of their life and also he also has
designs on grace's sister
millie who has down syndrome because to
him
it seems like she will be an even more
perfect victim because
i guess the implication being or at
least he perceives it that she won't
understand as much what's happening to
her because of her disability
even though as i said millie is
in a lot of ways like way more on the
ball than grace is
because i mean millie is kind of the one
that
actually like deceives people and
because hey i got all these sleeping
pills for you at the school and i did
all this stuff
so she's like doing all these but she
she figures out that like
jack is a [ __ ] and that i mean and
she's not even there she's like at the
school and she just like
you know intuits all of that and you
know so she actually kind of helps
grace get out get out of the situation
so
as it goes on as i said this just the
[ __ ] i don't want to go too much into
the details in case you want to read it
cause i want to spoil the whole the
whole book but
it just kind of ramps up and ramps up
and
jack is almost like like i said he's
almost
i want to say he's almost cartoonishly
evil i don't know if i want to say that
though because i know that there are
some people that are this [ __ ] evil
you know what i mean it's not like
you know it's not like this couldn't
happen it's just that
just like a lot of thrillers of this ilk
you do have to suspend your belief
disbelief just a little bit
because not only is he just like
completely warped and [ __ ] up and has
no feelings whatsoever
but he's also like a [ __ ]
mastermind about keeping her
under control i mean he's essentially
holding
millie's fate over her head all the time
basically like every time you try to
escape
because because grace does actually try
to escape at first i mean like any
normal person would
um but he's like every time you do that
you know we can't go see millie
for another week which really bums her
out because she loves her sister very
much and she very much looks forward to
you know their weekly visits or whatever
it's like so we're not going to do that
and it's like then you have to go in
this horrible basement room which is a
whole other plot point
he basically holds that over her like
threatening
her sister's life to get her to behave
the way
he wants her to behave because as in the
end he doesn't really give a [ __ ] about
grace um he's was just using grace to
get
at millie because he thinks that millie
will be the perfect victim for his
fetish i want to let a fear fetish i
guess he's really really into
and that's why he keeps taking trips to
thailand is because apparently i don't
know
if this is true if you guys are any of
you guys live in thailand and can tell
me
that he can go to thailand and pay
to torture women or have them be afraid
of him or something like that so that's
kind of
why he goes there so often but he wants
a victim that's more close to home so as
i said he doesn't really give a crap
about
grace at all he doesn't have sex with
her he just thinks it's gross um not
because he's gay or anything but it's
just it doesn't have
um if the fear isn't involved it's
really nothing to him it's it's
like a weird i don't know it's just like
a weird psychosexual thing
but it's almost like not sexual you know
what i mean it just seems like
that's the only way he can get off is
just by having people it's just by
torturing people and having them be
terrified of him you know what i mean i
don't even think it has anything to do
with rape or nothing
because i don't think that he even does
that to anybody in there so yeah so as
it goes on like i said it just gets more
and more depraved she
you know tries to escape she she tries
to
alert the authorities a few times of
course they don't believe her
because you know she's he basically
locks her in a room and starves her she
can't leave um
he won't let her have any books he won't
let her have a tv he won't let her so
she just kind of has to sit there and
stare at the wall
there's [ __ ] bars on the windows and
and she has to
wear exactly what he says has to do
exactly what he says it's like
she's not allowed to go outside
obviously she's not allowed to
you know go out with her friends unless
he's with her and um you know if she
messes up
like he gets punished she gets punished
rather like later on
so she's kind of in a bind and so i will
say
that grace is a character
this is another woman that it's kind of
it's all from the first person so it's
all from her
uh perspective i didn't get i got
something of a sense of her as a
character
but not really i didn't get a real
in-depth feel about her
and i will say that she's not unlikable
but
there were some points where i was just
like goddammit girl it's like why can't
you do this or why can't you do that or
you know what i mean
it just seemed like you know i hate that
to sound like judgey and everything like
that because i know some people are in
these kind of like
horribly abusive relationships
especially when it's
this kind of like psychological [ __ ]
going on
and i know that it can be very hard to
leave because you kind of get
ignored to to powerlessness and all this
other kind of stuff so i don't want to
sound like i'm [ __ ] on people like
in real life that have that issue
because i know they do
but you know in the context of a
thriller book you're just kind of
sitting there you wanted her
i wanted her to have a little bit more
fight in her i guess i mean she did at
the beginning
like she did actually try to escape she
did like hit him on the head with a
wine bottle one time and all this other
kind of stuff but it seemed like a lot
of her attempts to fight
it were a little bit lame that's all i'm
just you know
just take that as you will and as i said
it almost seemed like
so you know so the whole thing about her
and uh
you know millie coming to live with them
because of course jack is like super
excited
and telling everybody oh we love millie
so much and we're so she has her own
bedroom in the house and it's
it's so awesome we can't wait for her to
come live with us and of course
he can't wait for her to come live with
them because he's going to [ __ ]
torture the [ __ ] out of her but of
course nobody knows that except for
grace
so there's kind of like a time period or
like a time crunch
because millie is going to be leaving
the school
when she turns 18 and is going to be
moving in with them and grace is
basically
getting to the point where she's like
well i have to kill this [ __ ]
before
millie comes because otherwise we're
both [ __ ] but it seems like it takes
like she dicks around for a while and
then it seems
like it takes millie who at her
residential school
fakes insomnia so they'll give her some
sleeping pills and then she pretends to
take them and then she hoards them like
she stocks them up and then she sneaks
them to grace and be like
hey kill that [ __ ] basically
like billy says
because she's like he's a bad man like
he pushed her down the stairs at the
wedding and like everyone just thought
she fell and all this other kind of
stuff
so she seemed like millie seemed like
more of more kick-ass character than uh
grace did because millie was just like
man you gotta take care of this [ __ ]
like right now and i'm gonna help you do
it i'm gonna
you know give her give her a kick in the
ass because she definitely needed it
so it goes on like that it won't come as
a shock to anybody to find out that
grace actually finally does succeed in
killing the [ __ ]
i will say i like the way that he got
killed what they it's really weird
because
as i said it goes back and forth past
present right so what
ends up happening is that you find out
that he's dead because she had this big
elaborate she has this big elaborate
plan
but you don't know what the big
elaborate plan was yet because like in
the present
she's talking about you know she flew to
thailand
and she's talking about like all the
[ __ ] that she did like she flew there by
herself
so you knew that he had to be dead
because you're like well there's no way
that they would let her
that he would let her go anyplace by
herself because that's kind of his whole
thing
so she goes there by herself and then
she keeps calling
his uh she keeps calling his cell phone
and leaving all these worried messages
you know when are you coming home when
are you coming over i thought you were
coming after four days and blah blah
so you know that she's establishing an
alibi right
but you don't know exactly what happened
until the next chapter when
you know when you do a past and then it
says like how she killed the guy
now i will say i like it was kind of
satisfying
that he ends up getting killed
in a way that oh and also um animal
cruelty alert because something bad
happens to a puppy
in this so and the thing is it's like
the puppy is introduced like real early
thing i'm like that puppy isn't long for
this world i hate to say and i was
correct
that always happens in these thrillers
man every time they
mention like a puppy or a little kitty
or something like that
and it's like a big oh my lovely puppy
i'm like oh no
something bad's gonna happen to that
little critter and indeed it does
but so i did like that they kind of
called back to the horrible thing that
happened to the puppy
in jack's death i thought that was cool
but on the other hand it did kind of
seem like a lot of what happened to him
happened like off-screen if you know
what i mean
so you know they don't really show it
like they show
what she did to kind of put the whole
plan into motion
and then she like takes the [ __ ] off but
they didn't
show him suffering and
i guess i was missing that a little bit
because this dude is so [ __ ] evil
that it's like you just wanted him to be
[ __ ] torn apart by animals or
something
and you wanted to see it like all
they're in like visceral
just because he was such a [ __ ] you know
you wanted to see like you know you
wanted to see her like
peel all his skin off like or something
like you know what i mean
maybe i'm just a savage i don't know but
it just seemed like as shitty as he was
i really wish that yes the way he died
was like poetic justice yes it was more
realistic
her being you know she was half starved
she was kind of
crazy from being controlled by this
[ __ ] for a year however long it
was so she wasn't
exactly [ __ ] superwoman or anything
so she did what she could do and she
managed to pull it off but that said
i do kind of wish that it had been like
a little bit more i don't know a little
bit more visceral like shown more
like more bad [ __ ] happened to him you
know what i mean because he sucked so
much
but yeah this is a solid three and a
half four star read i think a lot of
people like i said i saw some uh
reviews people that really didn't love
it and they said oh it's not all that
original stuff which it's not
uh it's just a very standard like
psychological
marriage horror thriller type of thing
not real twisty um not real there's not
any shocks or anything like that it just
it's very straightforward it just goes
along yes you find out jack is a
psychopath almost immediately here's all
the ways that he's a psychopath here's
all the
methods that she was using to try and
escape here's all the methods that he
was using to keep her from escaping
so it was all that kind of [ __ ] going on
and then you know her coming to the
revelation i have to kill this
[ __ ] and then her killing the
[ __ ]
the end so um if that sounds like your
cup of tea
as i said i don't mean to sound
disparaging about it at all when i say
it's kind of like
lifetime movie-esque or something like
that but if it's just if you want
something that's like
i hate to say a light read but that's
kind of disturbing
like in a thriller fashion but
not so gory because there's really not
any gore in this i don't think i can't
even remember
anything really gory or bloody or
anything happening
i didn't find like some people have said
it was disturbing i said maybe
psychologically disturbing but i didn't
find it all that disturbing like i've
read way worse
so it just seems like a real quick
entertaining read that you can just
knock out in a couple days it's kind of
breezy it's like it's it's very simple
it's not real
complicated the prose is very you know
straightforward and
you know so if if you're just looking
for something in the thriller vein
that is just gonna be a fun read
and also kind of [ __ ] up then
definitely check it out
now as i said i believe they might be
making a movie out of this i feel like
they probably will because it was a
massive
bestseller uh in the uk actually all
over the world i think it was a
big vessel in new york times usa today
all that stuff
again this was her first novel and i
think a lot of people compared it to
gone girl girl on the train which i
haven't read either one of those but
from everything that i've
seen of some other reviewers that i
trust and stuff are like yeah it's
really nothing like that because those
are a lot twistier than this one and
this one was really not
but it was still fun if if that sounds
like your cup of tea then by all means
check it out
and i might be reading some of her other
books because as i said she's written
three more
uh in the future but we'll see how that
goes and uh that'll do it for this
tomes of terror and i will see you on
the next one bye